the first instance so for me once I
discovered all of that and I'd shifted
to to some weight and got to a healthy
weight I then chose for me to have
surgery that was that was the gift to
myself
so after I'd healed and I'd recognize
where the trauma came from and I dealt
with that trauma my gift to myself then
was to have surgery what kind of surgery
I had a tummy tuck good for you I've had
liposuction me too I've had my boobs
done I I had I had lip so I did so and
tying into the whole thing because a lot
of people try to like on me right
now because I got liposuction right
because I was just in such a bad place
you know why because I was reading
YouTube comments
everybody's just telling me this was in
like 2021 March I got it but I also was
fully transparent about it and I made a
full documentary good about it in Tokyo